all right so during the pandemic uh
magician
xavier mortimer took to social media
with his illusions uh while his live
show was temporarily shut down now some
of the videos
just broke the internet and broke all
sorts of records one of them was viewed
worldwide on facebook uh this was in
june of last year more than
354 million times it's really crazy how
he blew up and i i i saw those videos
some of the things he does they're
unbelievable
so entertaining and now a show is
officially opening at the strat theater
and jillian joins us live there now
hey you guys so yes we are back at the
strat theater and we are making the
magic happen xavier joins us again and i
have to say i think this is my kind of
trick that you have going on here you
have a martini glass so let's jump right
to the trick and show us what you got
here yeah i've got a very special drink
for you it's a martini but it's very
bubbly okay i like bubbles look at that
oh
stop
oh my gosh can i touch it go ahead okay
look at this how did you do that can you
tell us it's magic it's magic it's a
secret look how cool this is so we were
talking earlier you during the pandemic
in quarantine you really took over the
youtube world and your videos went viral
what types of tricks were you doing
while you're at home and was that just
something to stay busy or did your fans
just love it so i i started with
very simple things we were at home and i
i couldn't go out or perform in the
theater so i put all the tricks that i
had and performed them at home it took
off really well for me and
i started to do more elaborated and
crazy stunts
after that
and i it was not expected you know we i
kept creating and creating videos and
they took off one after another
um
and now with all we've been creating
during the quarantine we even
incorporated some of the the the
illusions that i created in the show oh
that's so cool so if anyone saw anything
on youtube that they really liked they
can see it here on stage what other
tricks and fun things do you do in the
show and people can see when they come
visit you here at the shot so the the
new things that i incorporated was one
that i went very viral that i was
floating on boxes in
in my backyard
and uh i did also one where i was flying
behind a cart at walmart in the show
yeah that's uh that was a a very good
one
um but in the show in general we're like
in a dream so there's a lot of things
there's uh bubbles of course there's
shadows i play with my shadow i i float
with the jump rope there's a lot of
things that i've been performing for
years and polishing and polishing and
now with the
extra illusions from social media
it's being like even better well you do
it all and if you guys want to come see
xavier he's here every night except
except friday friday night so come visit
him here at the strat theater just look
how cool this is these are the types of
tricks you'll see if you come and off
camera i might just have to ask xavier
how he did this i'll send it back to you
guys
you can check out xavier morty or the
dream maker nightly performances at 6 pm
at the strat theater dark on tuesdays
and get your tickets at thestrat.com
got more coming up right after the break